-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Guys, I'm super excited
about this.
The one and only, Dolly Parton,
is my guest tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Dolly!
Right now, thousands of people
outside are like,
"Screw the tree lighting.
I want to see Dolly."
Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm excited to ask Dolly
about her new Christmas special,
her new album,
and ask her for advice
on building my theme park,
Jimmy Wood.
[ Laughter ]
[ Guitar plays chord ]
I'm honored to have a small role
in Dolly Parton's "Mountain
Magic Christmas" special
tomorrow night on NBC.
I'm in it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, it was a big role.
It was a big role,
but after
five minutes of filming,
Dolly was like, "You know what?
Less is more."
And I thought it was nice.
[ Laughter ]
What a special night
to have Dolly here.
We actually watched
the Rockefeller Center
Christmas tree lighting
together,
and once it was lit,
I started singing...
[ To "Jolene" ] ♪ The tree,
the tree, the tree, the tree ♪
And I'll never forget
what Dolly said.
She said, "Stop that, please."
[ Laughter ]
It was just memorable.
That's right, tonight was
the 90th annual
Christmas tree lighting
here at Rockefeller Center.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
90th.
The crowd -- The crowd
spent hours
waiting in the freezing cold,
the pouring rain,
and 40-mile-per-hour winds.
But at the end of the day,
at least they had
a beautiful view of
the umbrella in front of them.
I thought that was...
[ Laughter ]
If you couldn't see the lighting
in person, good news,
the tree will be lit daily
from 6:00 a.m. to midnight,
just like everyone
who invested in crypto.
So, there.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
So, the tree is wrapped
in 50,000 lights
and crowned with a star
that has 3 million crystals.
[ Audience oohs ]
Meanwhile, all the other trees
in the city are, like,
"[Coughs] Desperate."
[ Laughter ]
"[Coughs] Sad."
Yep, during tonight's
tree-lighting ceremony,
50,000 lights
were turned on at once.
So, on behalf of everyone here
at 30 Rock,
I just want to say sorry
to the guy who lives next door
at 32 Rock.
[ Laughter ]
Let's see what happened
when they lit the tree.
Do we have a video of that guy?
-Time to dust off my collection
of priceless vintage glassware,
which I hope
nothing ever happens to.
Aaah! My eyes!
Aah!
-Oh, my God.
-My glassware!
Aah, my eyes again!
-Oh, he can't see.
-I'll get you for this,
Rockefeller Center
Christmas tree!
-I hope he's alright.
I hope he's okay.
-Oh, my gosh!
-I hope he's alright.
-Lucky he had a camera in there.
-Thank goodness
we had the video cameras there
to catch his reaction.
-Both his elbows went up.
-Yeah, I know.
But he knocked both shelves
there.
He didn't know what to do.
[ Laughter ]
-Such a blinding light.
-Yeah, I know.
Meanwhile, though, tonight
in Washington, D.C.,
people were celebrating
the 100th
national Christmas-tree lighting
with President Biden.
That's right. We had a tree --
[ Cheers and applause ]
a tree lighting in New York
and a tree lighting in D.C.
And then one guy in Philadelphia
microwaved a cheesesteak,
and the whole East Coast
went dark.
It's like, "Wait, wait."
[ Laughter ]
I read that the tree in D.C. is
about 55 feet shorter than
the one here in New York City.
[ Laughter ]
The national tree heard and
said, "Hey, it's colder here."
[ Laughter ]
But...
Well, everyone is still talking
about this.
The U.S. Men's Soccer Team's big
win over Iran in the World Cup.
Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's exciting.
I don't know if anyone's
more excited than Biden.
This is real.
When he found out the result,
he ran back onstage
after making a speech
to make the announcement,
but his mic wasn't on.
[ Laughter ]
I know.
Watch this. Watch this.
[ Marching-band music plays ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Sad tuba plays ]
-Biden didn't care.
He was finally
living his boyhood dream --
silent film star.
-Aww.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
[ Film projector whirring ]
[ Imitating film rewinding ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Some big news --
You can understand the movie.
Hey, here's some big news, here.
The Senate just passed
legislation to mandate
federal recognition
for same-sex marriages.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Man, if you thought Iran hated
America after the World Cup,
oh, boy.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, it's a big deal.
Right after it passed,
Biden awkwardly ran back onstage
to announce it, like...
[ Laughter ]
Switching gears,
today Prince William
and Kate Middleton
arrived in Boston
for their first trip to the U.S.
in nearly 10 years.
-Hmm.
-Right?
[ Applause ]
And this was nice.
This was nice.
They met with Boston royalty,
Matt Damon and Ben Affleck.
I think Boston is rubbing off
on Prince William.
Just listen to this video
from earlier today.
-[ Boston accent ] Bro,
did you see the Yanks
tank it this year?
I think Judge is coming over
to the Sox.
-Yeah, that's interesting.
-Wow.
-What's he talking about?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Get some Dunkin'.
-Well, everyone is talking
about this today.
Spotify released their
annual "Spotify Wrapped."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Do you all get it?
Yeah.
"Spotify Wrapped" is great.
It reminds me that I've
pretty much been listening
to the same five artists
for the last five years.
[ Laughter ]
Did you guys see this?
Following a massive
spike in sales,
"The Phantom of the Opera"
has extended
its final Broadway run
by eight weeks.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The Phantom was like,
"I was this close to
not having to wear a mask.
This -- I mean, almost."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, they announced
they were closing,
then got record sales.
Now Sears is like,
"We are also closing."
[ Laughter ]
Well, this is fun.
I saw that next month,
the world's largest
go-kart track
is opening in New Jersey.
[ Audience oohs ]
What took so long?
It's already the tracksuit
capital of the world.
I mean, come on.
[ Laughter ]
It makes sense, though.
New Jersey is the one place
you're actually gonna find
a man named Mario in a go-kart.
So...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Come on, that's...
"It's me...Mario."
And finally, guys,
it's Wednesday.
You know what that means?
It's time for
some "Monday Motivations."
[ Soft music plays ]
-"Monday Motivations."
♪♪
-Secretly, the Kardashians
are just trying
to keep up with you.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
Every time
you have an appointment,
your dentist
calls his friends like,
"You'll never guess
where my hand is right now.
Yes, Jeffrey's mouth."
[ Laughter and applause ]
When people see you in a club,
they're like, "Whoa,
how'd I get into
the VIP section?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
You wore a winter coat
last week,
and now everyone's wearing
a winter coat.
That can't be a coincidence.
Congratulations, trendsetter.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Every time people see you,
they're like, "Mistletoe?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
When you go down the line and
say what you want at Chipotle,
the workers are like,
"Right answer, right answer."
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally, you're the "you"
Mariah keeps saying
that she wants for Christmas.
That's why they play it
every time you go into the CVS!
All she wants is you!
[ Cheers and applause ]